welcome my name's uh
chad de pew i'm uh uh
founder of a consultant consultancy
called inaca
um and now the cto of company called
whisper text
i'm definitely an erlang fan uh an
eretis fan
uh and so i've sort of put those two
things together with uh some friends of
mine and uh co-workers uh to
do a bit of an experimental project that
i'm going to tell you guys about today
so really quick uh anaka is my company
we have 25 developers
doing a lot of high performance apps ios
and
android mostly typically funded startups
one of them actually was a company
called whisper
and they have recently
closed a series b and then i actually
sort of came on board with them
so they're probably the largest social
network that no one in this room has
ever heard of
um it's sort of a place to share uh
in a safe way you're sort of things you
don't post on facebook and twitter like
you know people spend a lot of time
managing their their um
personal brand like everyone has a
personal brand these days uh so this is
sort of a place where you can uh
you can not manage your personal brand
and
talk about the things you like actually
so really quick i'm just gonna i thought
it'd be kind of funny because it's
there's a lot of interesting stuff on
there uh so i
i found a few with the word conference
in them uh we haven't rolled out search
yet but you can
on the website it's actually totally an
app it's not really a web thing at all
uh yet but uh so it was like uh
i'm attending a psychology conference in
three weeks secretly i'm hoping i'll
meet the man of my dreams there
uh you know this is this kind of very
like sort of confessional
um hello sorry i mustache you a question
i don't know what that is oh did it go
away
sorry i didn't i can't i apologize here
uh that's really weird that it uh here
we go
so really quick um
they're all sort of like very
confessional and artistic um
uh some of them are very vulnerable i
miss my ex-husband he's sitting at me at
this conference and i made a huge
mistake so some of them are really
vulnerable
some of them are just kind of funny um
you know and they're all
a lot of them are sort of focused around
nearby so if you
you know uh in a place where you use
whisper you'll see people uh
um you know you'll see like it'll get an
alert that it's near you so there's it's
actually quite a big social network it's
about two and a half billion uh
page views a month so it's um pretty
large so
anyway um really quick let me fix my
display here i apologize i probably
shouldn't have gone off script here
all right so um so anyway i
in the course of of doing some pretty
interesting scale build
scalable projects um i came up with this
idea to build a redis clone in erlang
called edis um so redis is basically
uh i'm assuming most people here are
familiar with redis it's sort of like
you know
the swiss army knife of the internet now
so you know essentially it's a c base
it's really fast
uh it's disc backed but obviously people
don't really use it for that other than
just sort of
backup and you know edits is very
similar other than
it's actually um disk backed by default
and
it's actually more focused around having
larger than ram
keys uh you know key value stores so
um i just want to be really clear up
front too i love redis so this talk is
is sort of an homage to redis so it's
not a um
uh it's not to bash radius at all in
fact um
it's yeah it's sort of an inspiration in
many ways and also edis isn't fit to tie
the shoes of radis to be really clear i
mean this is an experimental project so
um really quickly so basically um
edis is an earlying based server that
uses a lot of the otp
behaviors gen tcp gen fsm it has a level
db backend by default
it doesn't have to use level db it's
pluggable and it
essentially respects the redis uh you
know big o times in other words all the
algorithms
uh that used in redis um are the same
in in terms of um complex time
complexity now in terms of speed it's
definitely slower but in
uh in terms of time complexity so uh you
know redis is obviously great because
it's fast and it's got these great
commands and it's really easy to deploy
um i don't know how many people are
really familiar with the redis commands
um
one i really like is uh our pop l push
who's familiar with that command it's uh
yeah a few people it's really
great so i can like create a work queue
um i can basically
throw some work in it ids whatever um
and then i can have another key
that's like a run queue i can basically
uh atomically pop from one and push to
the other
um and that you know i it's in some ways
in erlang a lot of these sort of things
are not as useful because erlang it's at
some level sort of
is a giant you know set of cues and uh
or or
mailboxes processes with mailboxes but
um particularly
in sort of higher level languages it's
really really powerful
so it's atomic and it um you know
it essentially allows you to do some
really interesting stuff around
making sure potentially you know uh
coordinating among for instance a bunch
of ruby or python requests uh
that are on separate servers so uh the
redis design decisions you know data's
uh in memory there was a long time ago a
non like you could do virtual memory but
it just didn't perform very well it has
a master slave model although
salvatore is working on a um like a
sharded cluster that's not out yet
um and then it has scripting so you can
do some logical stuff but
that sort of blocks the thread so one
thing i've found is that people that are
using
serious reddish is just don't use
scripting very much
um and they don't use sort of key search
because key search and scripting will
you know block the thread the other
thing i've found is most people will run
more than one redis on the server
because if they have like a four core
server that run for
red eye so they can um you know
get maximum use of the cpus so edit's
design decision is a little different so
it's dispatch by default has a plugable
db
um it has master slave and then we're
working on master master
and then it's extensible with erlang so
as i mentioned it respects the time
complexity and actually there's one
caveat which is with z sets
there's no concept of well there's no
off the shelf
implementation of skip lists and i
haven't had time to write it so
uh or anyone else so um z sets
has um i i think like log
n time complexity and um
and then edit sets as z sets or not
they're just uh
they're in so um use cases basically
um so there are people use that are
using edis what what i found is they're
actually using it more
as a proxy so they've taken like the
stuff that we wrote and they strip out
all the back and stuff
and they wrote their own like proxy
where they're sort of you know load
balancing as a smart proxy between
radiuses
so they have real redis behind the
scenes and actually using it to speak
the protocol
which is kind of interesting um and then
it's just kind of an interesting
reference protocol implementation so
i'm going to really quickly go through
kind of how it works we're going to
actually
i'm going to show you guys a bit about
how to build a server like this at
erlang
and then we're going to actually uh
trace through a command and we're going
to talk through kind of
the replication and a multi-master stuff
and then we might able to
demo multi-master so um
who here is like i guess i'm wondering
who here is not familiar with erlang
at any level okay good there's some
people that's great
so i'm going to give you the worst
overview of erlang you've ever heard um
so all the people here that really know
about erlang are going to
um give me like you know red cards at
the end of the talk
so um 45 seconds so pattern matching is
sort of the name of the game it's a
functional language um
variables are not able to be uh
reassigned um
it only has sort of a concept of like a
virtual machine with uh sort of green
threads
if you will um they're like these
lightweight pro processors that you can
have like you know
10 million on your macbook and you can
create them nearly instantly
um and essentially you can only pass
messages between these processes so
uh if you want to communicate like
erlang is actually incredibly object
oriented
if you think about it it's sort of like
almost the fundamental idea of object
orientation which is you create this
process and you can only pass messages
to it
and it has its own internal state that's
erlang so on top of that people build
this
build on top of erlang these sort of
really simple primitives
with this thing called the open telecom
platform it's called otp
essentially this thing called a gen
server is sort of the core building
block of erlang you'll see that
in here and a gen fsm is like a more
complicated version of a gen server
um these think of these as like loot
they're like little pieces little
process with an event loop that i can
send messages to and they're going to
basically do things for me um and the
other concept of supervisor tree
and supervisors can essentially manage
these servers restart them when they die
so like a normal erlang system would
never need to be rebooted
in theory because i can always like if
something dies just kill that one little
piece of it it's going to keep running
so if you want to learn more get all
three major erlang books
if you read joe armstrong's book you'll
become a ber leaver it's made up about
10 minutes ago i'm sorry
um but uh no seriously all three of
these major books are great um
and i really think it's worth learning
about early if you haven't um it just
makes you think differently even if you
decide it's not the right fit for what
you're doing
so i'm going to dive into the structure
of the app really quick so
essentially there's a supervisor tree so
um in early every app you'll see these
supervisors
you'll see uh essentially uh um
uh let's see if i can get to the i can't
do a pointer here that's all right
um you'll see the um the main supervisor
and it has a series of um
database list supervisors and then a
listener so um
if i actually uh when i boot up an edit
server it's going to actually
create an erlang process for each
database and it's going to create a
client listener
and a client manager so um i'm going to
kind of walk through some code really
here so
really quickly here so um essentially uh
this is typical you know erlang code
it's a little bit hard to read
uh at first but once you realize it's
very simple it's it's uh there's not a
lot of
sort of different constructs it's not
too bad so
um i'm actually going to create this
sort of list
of um listeners and uh
each listener is going to call uh the
youtuber i was going to call this
edislistener that's going to
the supervisor will create like a whole
group of these and you can see it on
there at the bottom it says okay one for
one
five ten listeners that means that um
it'll knows how to restart these things
and it knows that uh you know if if like
as long as not more than
uh 10 die in five seconds um
then uh it can just keep restarting them
so essentially it's sort of like
a little bit of a it'll sort of keep the
system running
so um i create those listeners
and then i actually uh those listeners
when a connection comes in
a client manager is created and a client
manager has these two sort of sub
processes like a client and a
um uh in a command runner
so what i can do is
the thing that's really cool about
earling 2 is it has a lot of great
sort of protocol tcp support built in i
can basically just say
i want to listen on this connection on
the socket i want to
i want you to actually send me the
inbound data
as uh packets that are line delimited so
i don't have to worry actually about
even parsing the uh
inbound protocol redis because redis is
a very simple text based protocol
and uh what happens is inside this
little uh
uh at its client here the uh
um we have a state and the state is
called command start
so command start is where we start we
have um
uh you know sort of a holding place
called
state here that holds our internal state
and essentially what we're going to do
is we can actually um sort of we're
going to traverse
through these different states it's a
finite state machine picking off pieces
of these commands
so you're going to see here basically
each
command is going to have at the end of
its return it says okay great i'm done
the next state is some other state and
then it's really complicated
the way they describe it but essentially
here's my internal state and here's the
name of the state i'm in so it's sort of
like
you're going to move around from state
to state and i'll show you an example in
a second
what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to be able to go in here
i'm going to skip ahead and show you
guys so for a typical redis command like
i want to you know set
a key value so i'm going to set my key
lang equal erlang
this is what happens over the wire
essentially um
there's a uh a series of commands we say
hey here's the number of parameters
here's the length of the first parameter
here's the command here's a link to the
second one et cetera
down to the end and these are all really
simple like text-based
commands that are carriage return line
feed delimited
and then the server is going to respond
so that's like actually quite a simple
state machine
and so we're going to do is i'm actually
going to show you guys sort of one of
the great things about erling in terms
of how it's very
easy to build a state machine that would
parse commands you know like a redis
protocol
so um at the top here you can actually
see
the uh the state we're in it says we're
in state
uh we actually our our process gets in a
message it gets a tuple which is this
little curly brace thing it says tcp
here's the port here's some data so star
3 which means
there's going to be three parameters and
we're in command start so then it says
okay i'm switching now to state arg size
cool
so now i'm going to hop over to arg
sites great now i'm there
okay so now i'm waiting on essentially
the number of arguments so the next
command that comes in
uh off the socket uh is okay great we've
got a new message tcp
uh here's your argument size okay
uh actually so i think it's funny
because i think the arg size yeah the
architect is correct because it's it's
set
so the next is the actual arc so now
we're in the command name state
so you can see up at the top here we're
command name state and uh we're waiting
now
on our excise again we have a command
what's next so we're going to hop
through
we're in the argument now we're in the
arc size again now we're back in
argument
now we're uh back in
[Music]
the the actual data that comes in and
each time so for instance here it says
dollar sign five is telling how how big
the data is so it's going to tell us how
much data is coming in
so we get that um and then we're
actually done
so at this point we know we got a
message
to run this command set with these
parameters and now we're going to run
that command so
at this point erlang did this work to
sort of like listen on a socket
it gets all these inbound messages it
doesn't even have to parse them it's
quite simple to just
get the actual run time to send you
these if they're if they're um
uh character turn line to be terminated
i've got a message now i'm gonna do
something with it
okay so at this point now i can actually
run the command
and um i'm gonna go into that in a
second so
our runner essentially is um there's a
couple different states you could be in
for redis so with redis you can actually
have other people that are subscribing
to you you can actually do this thing
called pub sub where i can like
um i can actually listen on a key and as
people publish to that then i'll
actually get the slaves will get those
messages
so we have a bit of a state there that
we need to walk through and i'm not
going to do that i'm just trying to show
you guys that it exists
um and then we're gonna you know run the
command
so uh we get this inbound message run
it has the command has the arguments we
say okay what are we going to do what
state are we in
we're in are we in multi-cue are we in
uh um
pub sub are we just in regular run mode
and then we actually run the command
so um and then we um
we actually we parse the command and
then we run the command so
at that point we said we got a set
operation we don't need to do something
on it
um we have been through the
the whole process of of parsing the
command and so now we're actually going
to
do the work of running it so in this
case
um in edits db i'm going to go back
really quick to show you guys
essentially a separate process so
um if you look here
the sdbs are actually separate process
so and in redis you've got one main
thread
everything's sort of its own there's
there's actually one just sort of giant
loop
everything happens in line in edis
essentially
every database has its own process so
they're all running in parallel
as commands come in commands can be
operating on different databases in
parallel
i would not say that makes it faster i
would say it just makes it different and
it
it's like some things are a little bit
different there are certain commands for
instance that expect they work across
all databases and this one doesn't
okay so what we do is we actually send a
message over to that database
and um now that database process is
going to handle it so here we go
um we call run
gen servers have a thing called call
where i say hey
here's the name of my server here's the
command and here's how much i want to
wait and they'll actually go
and and run that it'll pass that message
to that gen server it's going to run
so gen server call here that
call will actually cause code called
handle call to run on the database
and it's now going to execute the
command so the database is going to say
okay cool i've got a command
here's my arguments and you can see here
essentially on line 217
that the entire sort of database
structure is sort of
pluggable in other words i can write
commands to uh
the um to my database back-end that
as long as the backend knows how to
handle them um we can use any sort of
plug well back in so in this case we're
using level db we don't have to use
level db
and in fact i'll show you guys in a
minute i'm just going to use the end
memory database
so um so there we go so we've done the
the right um that actually causes
e-level db to do a write
and these are like the um if you guys
are familiar with react the bachelor
guys wrote bindings for level db uh that
we're using here
that are open source and then that'll
actually
you know cause that database to command
to be run that gives you a result back
we handle the result in a in a case if
you're familiar with erlang
there are cases everywhere so we handle
that we get okay we turn tcp okay and
we're done
so i'll show you guys an example of that
just a second actually just live
so really quick so we used we uh we
chose leveldb just
because it's um it's
pretty fast for a decent amount of data
we looked at doing nodb bindings but we
aren't using this uh
we aren't using the database backend
right now in production so we just
decided not to worry about it
a couple people have ford didn't add
different added different database
backends like there's a hanoi db back in
hanoi db is actually a pure erlang
version of leveldb
which is kind of nice you don't need the
c drivers but level db is essentially
it's great because it compresses the
data it's
fast and one nice thing about edis is
when i write something to edis
and i get the tcp okay i know it's
written to disk you can do that with
redis but it's not the default and
people typically don't think of redis as
something that
is um has any sort of sense of acidity
in terms of database rights typically
they sort of assume that
you know there's a delay of you know
anywhere from one to 60 seconds before
it gets written to disk
so um so what's different so there are a
couple of things that
uh basically um edits doesn't do
some of the the functions are database
dependent in other words when i save i
don't save the whole system
it only saves the database some of the
functions aren't totally implemented and
encoding is really inefficient
so we'll show you that in a second so
i'm going to jump into sort of the new
stuff that we're working on
the master slave replication and the
multimaster behavior
so uh with replication
essentially um the way it works in in
red is today
is the client the slave sends a sync
command and the master
either has the database flush to disk or
it will go flush the database to disk
so um there are sort of two database
formats in redis
um one's like an append only format like
a little bit more like couchdb and the
other one's a
rdb format that's proprietary and gets
written sort of in line
what happens is whenever you do a sync
command you actually get the rdb format
so it'll go build an rdb database
you know write it out to disk and then
it'll stream it across the wire so you
get this one
giant tcp dump so if you have like um
there's actually something good to know
if you do a lot of reddit stuff and you
do a lot of like
uh sync or you know slave up commands um
if you have like say like you know uh
200 you know 100 gigs of data in memory
and you do sync you're just going to
you're just going to slam your network
with that it's gonna send it every time
if you disconnect and reconnect it's
gonna send the whole thing again
so it's very inefficient um it works
well but it's got some some issues there
so the master may flush at the disc um
then the master sends it across the wire
to the slave
the slave saves it as its new database
file and then now the slave runs
essentially a monitor which just allows
you to monitor all the commands
so um masters can have multiple slaves
and actually i'm just curious who here
has been has done reddit's uh slave
uh configuration before so some
people a few people here i mean it's
actually quite powerful
you can have multiple slaves slaves can
have slaves um
slaves can um
accept rights or you can disable that so
that you don't accidentally connect to
your slave and write data and now you've
got you know two data visitors that are
out of sync
but you can't do multi-master so there
was i can't do set
a key on on one server
um instead of different from the other
server and then get those from the
alternate servers that just doesn't work
um if i you know say i want to set foo
one
and get it on the other server that's
not possible so
excuse me so uh there's no multi-master
in redis yet
now there's not really a plan for
multi-master like what he's working on
is essentially like a sort of um
sharded key space it's called redis
cluster
that allows sort of virtual shards to be
mapped across a set of servers
and uh i think it's actually pretty cool
i i think there's some
the protocol isn't totally baked yet so
i'm not i'm not i'm sort of reserving
judgment in terms of
what what the whether it's the right
solution for some of the problems that
people are having
um i do know for instance like pinterest
wrote an article recently on how they do
um all their their social graph is
actually on tons of sharded radices and
they just do it by hand they sort of
have a whole system for it so
um it's clear that people are having
this problem at scale
so addis multimaster is a little bit
different um essentially
uh we use gen server genser has this
really cool thing that if i have a bunch
of nodes on different servers i can just
do add cast
and it'll actually find those gen
servers on all the other connected
servers or nodes
and it will actually cast a message to
the same
server on other servers so um
actually whisper we use it a lot for
like local cache so if
uh somebody changes a or somebody sends
something inbound or like a reply or a
like or something like that
we can broadcast that out to all the
other nodes um and it
allows you to do this sort of really
incredibly simple cross
node communication with just one line of
code so um essentially when i do a set
of a key
it broadcasts to all nodes and uh
it uses gen server appcast so um
if for whatever reason a node
missed an update we're using vector
clocks to
determine that the node is uh that that
key is out of date it's not really that
you can test out a date you can just
tell it's not
a child of the key that you just
received so you can kind of tell um
a sort of um ancestry between the keys
by using vector clocks there are some
issues right now
so like we don't uh update disconnect
nodes on reconnect
and um so we
essentially um we will detect
so if we do restart we do detect that
okay the last time i connected
was older than or sorry newer than these
keys so i probably wanted to get a key i
should probably go ask and see if
somebody has a newer key and uh
that works pretty well so a lot of
people ask me sort of what is the cap is
everybody familiar with the cap theorem
uh who is not familiar with the cap
theorem
so the cap there is essentially there
you can sort of put databases into
in these sort of three i actually don't
really like cap theorems i hate
explaining it but
um it the point is basically that
databases have sort of uh three
different styles of
of a contract that they offer the the
client it can be
two of these three but never never all
three it can't be consistent and
available and partition tolerance it's
going to not have one of those
characteristics
i think my critique of the cap theorem
is that it feels like it's almost
impossibly
partition tolerant really anyway so if
you say i'm consistent and partition
tolerant
i'm not really sure i believe you um but
edis is essentially available in
partition tolerant in the sense that um
we're definitely going to return results
to you that are inconsistent if there's
a disconnect
and um we're not going to complain we're
not even going to tell you that
that's happening um and so i think
that's okay i think that like the goal
right now is just
this is almost more a research project
into sort of how what are some
um what are some spaces for database
technology between
a key value store like react in a um a
sort of
a very sort of solo node or server
key value store like redis so there
maybe there's something something in
between there
so anyway um there's a couple other
things um
that's that are coming one is if you
have um
a database like this and you want to do
things like uh
anchor like increment it's very hard to
increment in a way that makes sense
with multi-master because every master's
like oh sure you know great we had one
in the counter now we have two
and the other guy's like oh yeah sure we
had three in the counter now we have
four
and they can get out of sync or they can
be off by one it's very very possible
so um there's a thing in erlang called
gen leader
that allows us to essentially take a
bunch of servers and elect between them
which one is the master node so now i
can
take all those functions that really
need a central authority
and actually sort of decide okay great
we're going to use you know
uh we're going to use this guy to to
make that decision now there's a ton of
issues with doing that
which is why this is a very experimental
project it's i'm not recommending that
you go out and use this
particularly if you really need
atomicity because there's just a lot of
un unthought through edge cases here
um the other thing we want to do is
replication on reconnect in other words
just going to do what uh
what redis does so we can essentially
say hey give us the whole database
and we can either block or we can say oh
sure we'll replicate in the background
like redis does not allow background
replication
uh when you do a sync but addis does
because its background
processes are free in erlang um and then
finally we're going to do a bunch of
you know finishing replication for um a
few data types that are missing
we will do this thing called post commit
hooks which are similar to react that
allows you to sort of
run code when a key is set or key is
read
and then um we're going to try to
implement redis cluster
as a sort of additional reference
implement called a reference invitation
but an additional implementation of
redis cluster
so um yeah so anyway that's a
you know pretty quick overview um if
you'd like to help
please look at the source the number of
benchmarks
experiment with it there's a lot of
interesting stuff there
it's a really clean and well laid out
repository
and uh i definitely want to say thanks
to uh
my intern who did a lot of his thesis
work at uppsala uh
on on this project over the last couple
months so
um what i wanted to do is actually
before we do questions i'm gonna do a
quick
demo just to kind of show you guys
how it works and with regard to the
master multi-master stuff
so um
we just fix the
for some reason when you connect to the
wi-fi it says that you're in japan i
don't know if did you guys see that
my host name is jp now
okay so i have um
two um
nodes here and i have two telnet
telnets on the right and uh
erlangs on the left so
what we can do here is so these guys are
not connect right now so in early i can
do nodes and it's going to tell me the
world as it sees it
so i'm not actually connected and i did
that just to
sort of show you guys how to um you can
actually set it up where they auto
connect but it's not doing that right
now
so now actually they both see each other
so if i do nodes
uh bro one here is going to see bro2
and roach is going to see bro one so
they know about each other now
so what i can do then is i can if i
connect so this one's running on
6379 and then the other guy's learning
on 6380.
so i can connect and if i do something
like now like you know
um get you know foo
it's going to return this this is
basically null here i can say get food
it's going to
null so now i can like you know set
foo 2 to be bar 2 and then i go here
and food 2 is going to return it so then
i can actually change it here
um
oh i'll get food too the wrong thing
sorry
so again it returns the right thing so
essentially i can make updates on either
one
and they're actually going to you know
make allow you to
see the results on any node so that's
definitely fundamentally different than
redis and something that's
i think kind of interesting it's
something that there's a lot that we can
do and play around with it
i think one of the last things i'll just
show you guys i don't know if um
um is you can actually kind of see
a little bit more detail in terms of
what's happening with um
is anybody familiar with apmon or
narlang
a few people has anybody ever seen apple
on before one one person
two oh ten okay so
um essentially what i can do is early
has a sort of built-in runtime thing
that allows you to see all those servers
running
so whenever i started up the app
the application it shows you each
process on the entire
system and then what they supervise
so you can see here this client manager
has this one process connected
that's actually my telnet connection so
if i go in here and i
um i might be able to do this where you
can see them both at the same time
yeah i'll drag it out um
so what i can do is actually like
disconnect
hold on you'll see
the connections get cleaned up in that
monitor so if i connect it's like okay
you can see it actually like what's
happening here so i can do info
and i can see this is my uh um
my client supervisor and then i can see
like
you know this is my um
uh the client man the command runner so
when i run commands
this is the thing that's actually
parsing the command and that's going to
send a message over here
to whichever database i have
selected so
it's not the greatest ui but it's pretty
amazing you can do this so like you can
see each of the database servers are
their own process
and those guys are going to handle the
commands um you know that they come in
from the client
so um that's pretty much it i'm gonna um
definitely take any questions you guys
have um
and uh and yeah we can go from there
anybody yeah go ahead
yeah it's a good question so um
essentially uh
so currently it's uh latest wins
um and it's that's not a super
satisfying
solution in terms of like where we
wanted to want to go
so um we've thought about doing
something where it's like i can set some
sort of rule that's like
okay if the key is like you know foo
then i'm going to dump them into food
siblings so i can actually hang on to
that data and not lose it
so sorry i didn't repeat the question
but the question was if the um
if you detect an error with a vector
clock how do you resolve the conflict so
like in react
uh you typically have two options like
you either
either store all the results as siblings
and then whenever somebody asks for a
result it just says
gives you a special http error code and
says uh whichever whatever it is but it
says
uh you know multiple children or
multiple results and you have to
actually
look at the results and pick the one you
want in our case we essentially just
blast over the latest one so
it's not a great solution but it's
partially because um
i think redis is a protocol doesn't
really have that ability to say
without us kind of going off script to
say oh wait no no we don't know what to
do here
error multiple children we could do that
i just didn't want to do that
to sort of violate the contract with you
know right as clients
so any other questions yeah
um you mean like basically the lua
commands so
um we we haven't implemented them we did
stick a lua interpreter in there because
there's a couple that are
well supported on erlang but we haven't
finished it's one of those it needs to
be implemented um it's not hard because
lua could easily
operate on it the tricky part is um
like some of the the way we access the
database is obviously different so we'd
have to do a decent metal work to make
it
you know work
in erlang yeah and uh erlang's kind of
designed to
you sort of you basically can do it one
of two ways you can set up because lua
is really embedding set up as sort of an
in-proc
um thing called a nif like a
native inflated function or there's a
thing called a port which essentially
just
uh shells out to lua running in a sort
of a process
and handles this sort of mapping state
back and forth
i mean either one would work i mean
running low as a nif is dangerous
because if it crashes it takes the whole
vm down
and erlang one of the sort of contracts
you get for erlang is that it doesn't go
down
so typically you do it it's a slightly
slower way which is essentially you port
it
and use and uh you just write you know
the lua library that's in redis that
sort of says okay if i ask for
a key i can go actually back out of
early into early and get the key and
bring it back
so it's a decent amount of work and it'd
be awesome if somebody wants to do it i
just
just like you know pretty low on our
list so any other questions
um that's a really good question
like ease of implementation was one and
the idea was you could
you could maybe use different database
backends um
it's probably a bad idea because it
changes a lot of the behavior some of
those commands
so uh because in other words the saves
and some of those things aren't quite
the same
so we thought about undoing it but you
know
right now it just sort of is what it is
um i mean it's a little bit more
efficient in the sense if you have
different people hitting the
different databases um and they're all
in one gen server like
if every database calls in one gen
server gen servers are
sort of blocking if you will when
there's something being running in that
gen server in other words
messages come in they get queued up in
the mailbox and then they get executed
by that gen server
as they come in so if i'm setting sets
and gits and everything it's going to
sort of they're all going to queue up
whereas if they're in separate databases
they could be
running on different processors and they
won't sort of block each other
but it does sort of fundamentally change
the semantics of it so it's a little bit
you know unusual
you are if you use yeah if you use level
you are yes um i mean you could
like in the in memory case you you
aren't but i mean i really wouldn't use
edis for in-memory in the sense that um
if you expect it to behave like redis i
mean redis does back everything up to
disk every
30 seconds and we don't do that at all
it's actually more dangerous
so uh it's fun to play around with but
it's but better if you're gonna use it
just use the disk store
so yeah that's a good point uh other
questions yep
if
yeah i think it's probably better to use
one uh i mean don't run robin partially
because
um you know yeah if you have a net split
you're obviously gonna start
you're gonna you're gonna have some data
inconsistency right so
um at least the client if it knows it
lost connection to that server
can handle the fact that it's like wait
something's wrong i can't hit the server
anymore so maybe my guarantees as to
what's in there
are now changed whereas i'm
round-robining i don't
i don't really know right um i mean we
do detect like if
if you look on here if i drop the node
the other nodes notice it right away
it's instant
it's part of the great thing about
erlang is uh that
that's built in so like essentially when
i um
if i kill one of these nodes it's gonna
like um
you know you're gonna see it it's gonna
be tough to show you sorry um but uh
you'll see it right away so it'd be very
easy to handle that case on the on the
server side like whoa i just lost a node
okay all guarantees are off throw an
alert call call
a wreath saying do whatever you need to
do so
any other questions
okay well thanks a lot i appreciate your
time and great questions